Happy 500,000!
Thank you guys so much for subscribing to
my channel and for joining me on this scientific
adventure.
You know, if you got 500,000 people together
and we all held hands in a line, it would
stretch from Sydney to Melbourne or from San
Francisco to San Diego or from London to Inverness.
>> Oy.
What are you forming a line here for?
You are going to scare off Nessy.
>> Right.
So I suppose I should get down to answering
your question.
Go ahead.
Hit me with your best shot.
>> I understand that the sky is blue do to
Rayleigh scattering.
Short wave lengths get scattered way more
and blue light dominates because it is so
short.
If that is the case, why isn’t the sky violet?
>> Ok, here is the thing.
The sky isn't really blue.
It is bluish white.
So the sky is illuminated by the sun and the
sun in its all colors, but not equally.
The sun doesn’t emit that much red, nor
does it emit that much violet.
Most of the light it emits is kind of in the
greeny part of the spectrum.
Now as you point out, due to Rayleigh scattering
more of the shorter wavelengths arte scattered
and that is why the sky looks blue, because
it is basically the sun’s white spectrum
shifted a little bit towards the blue.
This is the spectrum of the blue sky.
And, as you can see, it is quite broad.
And, in fact, there is a fair amount of violet
light in there.
But there is not as much violet light as there
is blue light, because the sunlight that we
started with had much more blue than it has
violet.
>> If I have a lap top on the international
space station with a hard disk drive in it,
will the torque from its spinning cause the
lap top to spin as well?>>
Well, by the law of conservation of angular
momentum, yes, the lap top should spin.
I did a quick back of the envelope calculation
and I found that if you spun up your hard
disk from rest up to 5400 rpm, then it would
cause the laptop to spin in the opposite direction
at a rate hat would cause it to do about one
revolution every 17 seconds.
>> What would happen if you poured liquid
oxygen on a fire?
>> Kaboom?
>> Say you were able to pass the event horizon
a black hole and come back, what would coming
back look like of the person and for an observer?
>> Well, to an outside observer it would look
as though you never came back at all.
And to the person it would look as though
you didn’t come back either, because once
you are passed the event horizon, that is
it.
Your entire future lies within the black hole.
And it will only be a matter of seconds before
you are in the singularity, the very core
of this black hole and you are no longer.
Now if you could bring a rocket back with
you and try to fight it, if you tried to accelerate
away from the black hole, you would find that
you actually live for less time.
You might see more space, but your time would
pass more slowly and so you would end up in
the singularity sooner.
So I guess the lesson is don’t fight it.
If you want to live longer, just relax and
go with it.
>> You have met a lot of interesting people
on your adventures.
But is there someone specific that you would
love to meet?
>> I would love to meet Bill Nye, Neil DeGrasse
Tyson, Richard Dawkins and President Obama
as a non scientist inclusion.
I really like his book.
So if you haven’t read The Audacity of Hope
that is a good recommendation.
>> If all the galaxies are constantly accelerating
away from each other, will they ever reach
the speed of light or stop accelerating all
together?
>> So, yeah, all the galaxies do seem to be
accelerating away from each other, faster
and faster, which makes this kind of a unique
time in the history of the earth, because
right now we can still see that there are
hundreds of billions of galaxies.
But sometime in the future due to the expansion
of the universe, those galaxies will be so
far away and, yes, they will be receding at
faster than light speed and then you might
say: Well, nothing can go faster than light.
And it is kind of true in that these galaxies
won’t be moving through space at a speed
faster than light, but the space in between
us and them will be expanding at a rate which
means they will be moving relative to us faster
than light, if that makes any sense.
So their light that they are emitting will
never be able to reach us, because it will
never be able to make progress through this
expanding space.
It is kind of interesting to think about what
will happen as that time approaches.
Well, the light that is coming from those
distant galaxies travels across this expanding
space.
And so it becomes red shifted, cosmologically.
And eventually the wave length of this light
will be so big that its wavelength is the
size of the whole universe and that is impossible
to detect.
So at some point, probably about two trillion
years in the future we will only see our local
cluster of galaxies.
Now the reason they haven’t gone out to
infinity, or very, very far away is because
they are gravitationally bounded to us.
So even though space is expanding on a large
scale, the gravitational force is enough to
hold all of us together so we will be in it
for the long haul.
But this still means that there is going to
be strange cosmology.
If we are still around trillions of years
from now, if we tried to look out, we would
see a very different universe, a universe
which is much emptier than the one we see
today.
So we live at a unique point in space time.
We should appreciate that.
>> Is there such a thing as randomness in
the universe?
And if so, isn’t that contradictory to science?
>> Yes, I think there is randomness in the
universe and, no, I do not think this contradicts
science.
Though, perhaps you are thinking along the
lines of Albert Einstein when he said: God
does not play dice.
He wasn’t happen when in quantum mechanics
it seemed as though some events have probabilistic
outcomes.
I mean, he thought that there were some hidden
variables there and we just didn’t know
what was determining the outcome.
So we thought it was probabilistic.
But all experiments seem to show, up to this
point, anyway, that there are some things
which are randomly determined.
They are probabilistic in their nature.
For example, you can get quantum, random number
generators and even the FBI and CIA can’t
seem to find any pattern in those numbers.
So they really, truly do seem to be random.
So, yes, it seems from all the experimental
evidence that randomness is a fundamental
part of our universe, albeit mostly on the
quantum scale.
>> What shape is the universe and could light
from our sun go around the universe and come
back and hit the other side of earth?
>> The shape of the universe seems to be flat,
which means there is no large scale curvature
of space time.
And the supposed reason for this is inflation,
this idea that very, very shortly after the
big bang the whole universe just started accelerating
at an incredibly fast rate.
So even if it was kind of wiggly or warped
or curved around on itself before inflation,
after inflation it basically would have been
flattened out, just like blowing up a balloon,
that side is going to become, you know, more
or less flat.
So within the limits of our observational
capabilities to these days, we think that
that the universe is flat.
So if you go out in one direction you probably
shouldn’t return the way you came.
So, no, the universe does not appear to be
closed and you would probably never see the
light coming up behind you.
>> Hey, man, I have one fantastic topic for
you to make a video about, but I need your
response.
You want to do it?
Otherwise I contact Vsauce.
>> Hey, Michael, you want this one or shall
I take it?
>> No, no, no.
Go ahead, Derek, take it.
>> So we are really reaching the atomic size,
but not in some exotic laboratory device.
In every device you have in your computer.
>> How many transistors are on a chip now?
>> About a billion.